why did a de took resort to the public
to raise money in the first place he
desperately needed money I mean he
founded modern Turkey from the ruins of
World War one and he needed capital you
know to build his republic so he turned
to the public he also turned to foreign
investors he got that got the match King
of Sweden to invest in his central bank
and as you said a lot of people did that
as he said the central bank last year
was the most profitable joint stock
company in Turkey making about five
point six billion dollars but yet
because none of these shares are traded
the Treasury gets the lion's share and
the rest of the shareholders get
basically nothing Evon and we saw quite
a bit of an emotional annual meeting I
mean to the descendants of the original
investors stand any chance here of
getting a bigger share of the central
bank's profits the emotional scenes
you're quite right about that what our
reporter attended that General Assembly
and and and there were even people who
were brought to tears and one of the
shareholders said that her father bought
42 shares in 1931 and deposited around
four thousand liras in that year and she
says that's in today's terms she's worth
those shares are worth more than a
million dollars and so she had to queue
for hours to get pennies now will they
ever see their money back it depends on
whether the settlement can be reached
between them and the government because
again there's no market for these shares
to be traded
I like the few other central banks that
are publicly traded already yeah
Switzerland I think in a few other
countries where they are publicly traded
but let's talk about the economy in
general one big challenge of course in
Turkey is that it still suffers from a
capital shortage today right that's true
I mean I don't know if it's AG it's not
mainly acute as it was in World War one
but they still need foreign capital they
still need capital that's why it's one
of the main vulnerabilities of the
economy that's what Turkey depends on
money depends on foreign inflows in its
debt market and stock markets to
actually finance its current account
deficit it's not acute but it's still
it's ironic that's still the same
problem more or less